escribe siete octavos como decimal y
como porcentaje que haremos aquí y aquí
vamos a escribir estos dos números ya
veremos para que esto sea mucho más
sencillo siete octavos
recuerden que siete sobre ocho o siete
octavos literalmente significa siete
entre 8 el numerador entre el
denominador 7 entre 8 no 8 entre 7
numerador entre denominador y para que
nosotros tengamos este decimal va a ser
muy sencillo simplemente hacemos la
división como normalmente lo hacemos
vamos a hacerlo de este lado
7 / 8
y para que todo sea como mucho más
sencillo vamos a agregar los puntos
decimales ya que sabemos que nos iremos
a decimales más allá del punto decimal
hasta que tengamos una respuesta con
residuos cero o un patrón de número
repetitivo ya los hemos visto
anteriormente me aseguro de tener el
punto decimal exactamente en la misma
posición y empiezo mi división como
normalmente lo haría cuántas veces cabe
8 en 7
0 por 8 es igual a 0 7 - 0 es igual a 7
vamos a bajar el siguiente
número que en este caso es nuestro
primer valor posicional de las décimas
70 70 entre 8
8 8 x 8 64 si a 70 le restó 64 36 tomaré
otro color
ahora bajaremos el siguiente 0 el 0 que
se encuentra en los centésimos
60 entre 8 y 8 por 8 fue 64 vamos a
multiplicarlo por 7 esta vez
7 x 8 56 a 60 el resto 56 tendré 4
y vamos con el anaranjado ahora bajar el
siguiente 0 en los decimales que ahora
son las milésimas
40 entre 8 es igual a 5 porque 5 por 8
es igual a 40 y 40 menos 40 es igual a 0
ya tengo un residuo igual a 0 y con eso
tenemos nuestra respuesta vamos a
escribirlo aquí abajo siete octavos será
igual a cero punto 875 milésimos y con
eso tenemos ya la respuesta en decimales
fue muy sencillo una vez que tenemos la
respuesta en decimales es mucho más
sencillo sacar los porcentajes de hecho
literalmente lo único que haremos es
multiplicar por 100 y recorrer el punto
decimal hacia la derecha agregando el
símbolo de porcentaje tal vez eso tenga
sentido y se los voy a explicar de dónde
o por qué funciona recuerda que estos
875.000 decimos los podemos representar
también como 875 milésimos así los hemos
representado o lo podemos representar
también como 80
7.5 sobre 100 porque porque estamos
dividiendo tanto el numerador como el
denominador entre 10 recuerda que
porcentaje significa
por ciento por cada 100 y de hecho aquí
ya tenemos 87.5 por cada 100 lo que nos
dice 87.5 por ciento y es así de
sencillo
como sé
si mi número es correcto cuando tenemos
un decimal simplemente multiplicamos por
100 recorriendo el punto decimal hacia
la derecha un par de veces y agregamos
el símbolo de porcentaje
87 puntos 5 % un tipi que tal vez les
funcione es pensar que si tengo mi
número decimal este siempre será más
pequeño que el porcentaje y será más
pequeño en un factor de 100 por que
875.000 decimos son más pequeños en un
factor de 187.5 ahora que si colocamos
el símbolo de porcentaje entonces
sabremos que 87.5 por ciento es igual a
875 milésimos simplemente interpretados
de diferentes maneras